sophia genießt mit ihrer mutter julia
die letzten tage der großen ferien
am donnerstag kommt sie in die zweite
klasse ihrer schule in kiel und heute
begleiten wir die beiden beim einkaufen
die siebenjährige braucht noch allerlei
utensilien für das neue schuljahr
ich möchte den stift diesen von denen
trotz des krieges können die beiden
alles einkaufen was sie brauchen hier im
schreibwarenladen herrscht noch kein
mangel neue ware zu bekommen ist aber
schwierig und russische produkte will
hier niemand mehr haben sofia hat alles
bekommen was sie braucht
wir haben alles mögliche für die schule
gekauft
einen farbkasten
stifter und sowas
knete übungshefte und andere farbe
damit werde ich was schönes malen
eine vase und bäume vielleicht die
bilder werden dann aufgehängt und in den
pausen werde ich herumlaufen und all das
machen was mir spaß macht
auf all das musste sie seit beginn des
krieges vor über einem halben jahr
verzichten seitdem gab es unterricht nur
noch online
und auch der wurde immer wieder
unterbrochen von luftalarm
ich hatte keine angst
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen herum gelaufen
manchmal habe ich mich im badezimmer
versteckt
jetzt freue ich mich auf die schule wir
haben lustigen unterricht die bringen
uns der coole sachen bei und wir basteln
da wir malen alles macht da viel spaß
sophias mutter julia hat lange überlegt
ob sie ihre tochter mitten im krieg
wirklich wieder in die schule schicken
soll sie hätte auch online unterricht
wählen können
unsere schule ist nicht so groß der
lehrbetrieb ist sehr gut organisiert
wir haben dann alles gedacht
wir haben uns auch den bunker gezeigt
für mich ist es die richtige kombination
aus sicherheit und unterricht ich finde
den präsenzunterricht besser als
homeschooling bei dem mann die tochter
ohne freunde und lehrer auskommen muss
wir werden das jetzt mal probieren und
wenn es nicht klappt kann man das immer
noch ändern
verglichen mit anderen städten ist es in
kiew im moment vergleichsweise ruhig
manchmal heulen die sirenen aber raketen
sind schon länger nicht mehr
eingeschlagen in der letzten ferienwoche
wurden die kinder hier nochmal daran
erinnert dass krieg ist am
nationalfeiertag haben sie erbeutete
russische panzer ausgestellt die schule
wieder aufzumachen das war keine leichte
entscheidung
die heizung serie gehen wir hat
oberste priorität und deswegen die
kinder gehen der schule das muss auf
jeden fall
die muscheln verfolgen die klare regeln
an regeln und den schulhof ein bunker
für
notfälle seien die kinder muss wenn die
bekommen eine alarm müssen unbedingt
sofort in bunker eine sicherer platz
zu bleiben
damit lastet jetzt große verantwortung
auf den schulleiter rektor jahreslauf
pauli muss sicherstellen dass sophia und
alle anderen kinder seiner schule einen
platz im schutzraum finden
wir haben hier 95 quadratmeter der
katastrophenschutz schreibt pro kind
etwa 0,8 quadratmeter platz im bunker
vor also können 95 personen hier
unterkommen jede klasse hat ihren
eigenen bereich
die kinder können hier sogar spielen
oder mit ihrem lehrer sprechen wir
wissen ja nie wie lange der luftalarm
dauert
für julia und alle anderen eltern ist es
schon ein großer schritt ihr kind bald
jeden tag für ein paar stunden der obhut
der lehrer zu überlassen aber auch die
pädagogen sind gespannt auf den
schulbeginn
die kinder werden kommen und erzählen
wie sich ihr leben seit dem 24 februar
verändert hat aber sie werden immer noch
lachen sie glauben dass alles gut wird
das schwer
ich glaube das wird ein toller tag nach
allem was wir durchgemacht haben wir
haben uns gegenseitig so vermisst wir
haben den klassenraum vermisst die
bücher und hefte aufzuschlagen
etwas zu schreiben unsere erlebnisse
miteinander zu teilen einfach nur
zusammen spielen ich wünsche mir das so
sehr
längst nicht alle kinder werden morgen
zu ihren büchern und schulsachen
zurückkehren
600.000 sie mit ihren müttern ins
ausland geflohen andere bleiben bei den
eltern zu hause aus angst vor
luftangriffen auch nicht alle lehrer
werden jetzt schon wieder an ihren
arbeitsplatz zurückkehren
sofia ist mit ihrer mutter in die schule
gekommen extra für unser interview für
sie ist es ganz natürlich im klassenraum
das übungshefte aufzuschlagen und ein
wenig zu rechnen ihr lieblingsfach ist
mathe
ich werde ganz viel lernen
englisch
schreiben
was mir am meisten spaß macht
mathematik und ich mag lesen ich habe
viele bücher
lehrerin larissa ist sich sicher dass
auch die anderen kinder gerne wieder in
die schule zurück kommen online hatten
sie auch während der ersten kriegsmonate
ständig kontakt miteinander
wenn die kinder gehört haben dass in
meiner stadt luftalarm war sagten sie zu
mir larissa du solltest jetzt in dem
bunker gehen dann haben wir die kameras
abgeschaltet und die stunde beendet sie
haben sich sehr erwachsen verhalten
44 und weit über drei millionen anderer
kinder in der ukraine beginnt morgen der
unterricht mitten im krieg
[Musik]